ポケモンカード再度1000枚やったら1
等あるゾーン
本日は初めてちょっとじゃあな一大出題さ
れポケモンカード好きでしょ大好きですよ
トークも大好きなんですよポケモンカード
のルール結構簡単で基本的なルールとして
は再度っていうのがロックもやるん
ポケモンを倒すと限りちょとれますとで
合計6回ポケモンを倒して再度ちょっと前
に撮った人達ってるーそれ分かりやすいか
不死身なんですけど香港で再度お互い
500枚500500で仙台再度済みさせ
ていただきました
[音楽]
[拍手]
2政治ね自分で起こったわけですよ私中
ことがはないポイントすごいかつ行ったり
したことで大破社員と取れば勝てるカード
ゲームチャイと戦略だった率はだからって
言う純正が疑問を買ってたので半年強もう
ライバルの
グリーンた
ティマーを頑張ってもいいっにマヨパン
ヌード
[音楽]
ブーブー今日は眠いまん
させている new deck 4 uv
が私はですねこの日のために作ったを特殊
デッキを爪+ラー人で特殊ルールなんです
けど入っちゃにこのおいているサイト
1000枚まあスタートで客からランダム
に選ばれたころですはいこれをたい時に
撮った程度に来るで強いを使って大丈夫
oo 戦略の幅が広がる広がり出して
いこうあんたの客にして守るうえおそらく
起こりうる可能性としては山砕きでんん
女だけでがどうしても怒るところで役だが
切れたらどうしますどうしも多分てくだか
ポケモンを買っていると補充できるから
うん読者になってやるから見れましたとか
はい東京痛くなりましょうとかありますっ
大丈夫にもポルソンへ
引っ込ん殺すぞ
ています
ブーブーちょっ
ちょっに生き餌
とそこそこを自分をキャッチ系お願いし
ます何願いいただきますバトル
したぞ
[音楽]
rar
発色でっぽい
戦後いただきます
食べません今
a はいコーラスね去年で2位だったに
入ってるます
名前ですはい名前ではーいましたました
お願いいたします
閲覧いいですちなみに排気かけていては今
ないん
big でタイプへと費税の不備ボール
使いますはいえっとまず裏になっている
自分の最後の表をすべて見る背に売らず
かけしますね街で言ってるの家
[拍手]
[音楽]
ブーバー
し
[音楽]
ブーバーし
クロスちゃってくれます
太平に見せて id ボール保持で帰って
いるハイ見たサンゴや家がいたカードは裏
にして切って最後どうしておきますね
入った
[音楽]
上から何も一緒にします1313入ってみ
ました13分下にしたんでこれからはた
サイトじゃあバイ編を見てきますはい
おっ
はい500円あけました
数が私ました
a day with ですはい思います
はい
13分かかります
やっぱもらい大変さ
定期の積極を出します
週刊させますそれのままか出来ませズバッ
ねっ24歌ってます最初の番最初のられ
ちゃうっ
カーボエネルギーはいっ
します方と使えません
これを
がここで入っ
入ってもらいたいわずかでもハイサイ
クーチャー2人まずやっぱり最後だろうね
v ジャン入ってる見えますはいはい違う
柄はない
上り線の考えですか490キロ a 愛と
思いましたーい
[音楽]
ぐらいの経営者はってますバルドたくて
ぶっせんのザク選択なので320点です
ただしこのときも53に食って吐い v 子
ゲームならですよ2枚ございますうわぁ
それでもありますはい
プロフュージョンデー
ハイファイブのもよし
わーるど太鼓160点の弱点のでサビ水辺
亀裂でサイト3枚もらえますはい入手よし
よし山山山用野菜等5枚とりだぜ普段のお
気かだったらあと一枚一曲でしたことだ
から俺が昇りサイトは
495バイ
[音楽]
ワールドタックル
160点のザク前に3秒ミルクできるん
です
03頑張りますはい
[音楽]
ぐるっと辛いですね
怖い
[音楽]
userchrome to
do
[音楽]
ブーブー
hej03言われたけどきたので r
ラッシュアブディン入って考え全部戻し
ますはい欲しいか道路登ってみたいと思い
ます
ブーブーアップしますはい工事追加しまし
たホット枚数がエイター1選手5枚以下
作詞家2125万円とりました愛知時間
25枚なので zune 直で250倍た
ず計算でいくとへ40時間かけ
第二橋亭主のですそうですねちょっと
アロマんぜまたもやてると4度時間なら
もう買ったからない方が出てくださいそう
だね殴ってもらえるバルネームを用意する
も極刑でつくんわかめて v max た
だけお客んで俺それ全部元 a 倒すから
送っございますよ4
開けてどうぞよしもう何もできないの板
はいっちょっとまだの怒り機械で
ame裁判所にバレました
でを買っても活躍
はいあなたの負けです
今回は特殊なの出会い戻してあげ戻して
ください
[音楽]
ん
じゃあ家族がいますえっ第二ングソード
自分がすでに取ったサイドの舞してかける
50ために追加です僕には再度29枚撮っ
ているので金470点ダメージですすっ
てっ
気絶レッツ合いもありますどうぞ
外部床研究者も柔術やってるぞいさあ材質
が俺は再度40万一つ40枚後460枚だ
バーン
バーンほど以前にグッズって売って
[音楽]
103順天の長尺が260年策定じゃーん
さあ
やバエ
植えてくれたです今ございます
[音楽]
日ベンチバーと分60点+ iad が
寸前にとっとさえの mice 受ける
幼虫ダメでついたあなたは十三参りたいと
思いますいろいろ書店等が込みで560点
切る通信は個別コスメ小枝を爪超えた
ついにやっと十分の一
1/10
[音楽]
っぽいない友達が良い
やっほぉ
コメディちょっと
[音楽]
2時間で行かせました
圧倒的にも協力者って僕を勝たせている
方向に動いていますに続き頑張っていき
たいとおもいます
取った際の枚数が在日君が18万いい僕が
90枚ですさあまた先月末米第二ング
ソード
450210分季節ですね
[音楽]
や単塾たんか
歯が山のようにあります
だめ
じゃんと思った
パッチし頑張れた
は
[音楽]
ブーブー
言っ
はについてなかった
はーはっはっは
ええええええ
[音楽]
まだ塗っている今ございます
でしょうかはい
[音楽]
ねルール違反するとだった登ります
れる方ができません
[音楽]
戻して重い
とあっ
おっん
はっはっはですね
いやよくないん
[音楽]
のしかかり読みますこれコインを1回だけ
思ったら相手のバッグ俺も持っていっ
ただ2006
ん
[音楽]
250枚ファイト取れました
俺のトラッシュそして俺の手管みて
ください
札でしょ
822時間54分くらいなんでだいたい3
時間ぐらいでサイト半分とれるんでまぁ
こんなままのペースでいくと6時間6時間
もうぜひだけな気がするんじゃ意見って
絶対して超攻撃型うつを参加バッケン産だ
けどねちょっと協力急ぎましたはい
ポケモン買ってあってはいけないて
くださいね
[音楽]
beaまだ覚えてみたい今
思います
バッハいきます weekly ペッい
ません終わります
はっはい
ていますええええええ3年前行きました
ゴーヤ301万円
旅立ち君とれますねコミュニケーションを
取れていてまるでお正月の voce 月
からような最後の一歩ということによって
おりますね上の場所はい
終わりですはいどうぞ
12ボルト
をご覧下さい
[音楽]
ああああああんじゃ私はですねえとべきペ
2部員を着ずにで要望でお願いますはい
じゃあ全部裏にしてシャッフルしてもらえ
ますか
[音楽]
あああああああったので並べたので続行し
ますはい
同カードの配布には
これを奪っていたい
by をれしゃぶらやってるの俺
兎虎いってるッ
[音楽]
どうぞから
みんないったぞをもずらーーー
[音楽]
まずの中に2枚など
残り歳の9枚切る
[音楽]
ん
これがん
[音楽]
ブーバー式 paddy
イカロスぞ
スーパーボール遊具祈っ
終わりですますまだ次回
3枚もらえますやばい沿い再度5万円
やはり負ける負ける分るよじゃ妄想分
新から凍ってます200いますなるほど
新刊終わります
これは私の気を付けます入ってる61枚
トラッシュしてもらえまいします
まあどやはり自分の投資にあるポケモンの
枚数をかける縦断 to
do 1010対戦中健記述バーキン
ヌードれますコアじゃあもう
配布 uv max ですねとおい
を4 wd ターボエネルギー
クロス救助
広瀬不得意のて黒バスとんです技術は行き
ましょ
まあ f 8部いうふうに立って氷の祭典
の後に3階第一君のばかりが出るボケも
あっムーヴいな
3枚もない道でははと宣言しますはい大臣
嘘吐い20点+自分がすでに取ったサイド
の枚数をかける50の面通過
俺がすでにトッドサイトの枚数は497位
497かける50は2番4850
24810立つ20で2枚持ち870第一
すぎるぜッ
[音楽]
しゃあああああ
私ありがとうございました
あるある歩い
というで再度1000枚でポケモンカード
したらマーキュリー系ある人と奴でも3
時間50分22秒
10時間近くかかるということがわかり
ます
最初真面目に本気でおたがいかずに行こう
としたら多分あのペースだと40時間も約
2日間かかりそうだったのでかといって
やっぱり第一か月なくて本どんどん行って
も結局も4時間近くかかるということが
わかったので再度って6万が一もいいん
ですかねされた504カードの戦いだと
エルレイド v だったり取ったサイトの
マイセンかける5する
[音楽]
voodooana